i hope my talk is information learning
and incentive design for societal
networks
today's societal systems are
a rapidly embracing an exciting era of
digitalization
and at the center of digitalization are
the technologies and platforms
these prep these technologies and
platforms are able to provide
recommendations and services to a large
number of human users as well as the
operators of the societal systems and to
consume the facilities of the
infrastructure
these technologies and platforms are
made possible thanks to the rich source
of data that is collected both from the
human users as well as the sensors
embedded but
embedded in the infrastructure
facilities
well
despite the advanced
technology capabilities things are not
always right
so here are some examples
well in fact there are a lot of protests
not just in la but also in bay area as
well as in boston
that calling for the uh
calling for the google map and apple map
to stop uh routing so many travelers
into the short neighborhood because they
really send too much traffic to these
small areas
during the morning rush hours
on the other hand study also showed that
uber and lyft finally admitted that they
are actually making the traffic worse
especially in the mecca cities due to
the fact that too many people shift from
public transportation systems to use
these writing
right-handling services
the reason is that these new
technologies and services
can in fact sometimes worsen the
misalignment of individual incentives
and the societal welfare
moreover although autonomous driving
technologies can potentially free us
from driving in the future it may not
free us from congestion
and one professor
professor john walker from berkeley cee
actually showed by a very smart
experiment that robot taxi may increase
the total miles traveled by
over 83 percent which is a very large
number and congestion can get much worse
the reason here is that the technologies
of autonomous driving is still
subject to the constraints of the
physical infrastructure capacity
not to mention that the uh
we need to keep in mind that
increasingly deployed sensing and
control units in infrastructure that
support these platforms can potentially
make our systems very vulnerable to
various random and adversarial
disruptions
well these real world issues really
bring forth the importance of answering
the following design question
that is what is the impact of these
technologies on today's societal systems
how they affect the strategic
interactions of their human users and
system operators
as well as how can we leverage these
technologies to really design the system
in order to improve the societal outcome
to answer these questions uh it's very
important to notice that the outcome of
societal systems
are governed by
both the aggregate strategic
interactions of their users and system
operators
as well as
governed by the physical constraints and
the stochastic dynamics of the networked
infrastructure
well classical economic theory or
engineering system theory often
emphasizes one aspect but less on the
other
the main message that i want to convey
here is that it really needs to build a
framework that accounts for both the
human behavior and institutions
as well as the dynamics and
stochasticity of the engineering systems
and the research objective
so my own research objective is to build
such a framework and here i take the
inspiration from game theory mechanism
design machine learning optimization and
control
in order to build new models and new
design
guidelines
my time is limited but i will try to
briefly
convince you that this is a good
approach
of solving the design problem
by some of my work
um the first part is the value of
information and information design
so people are more and more relying on
these navigation acts to make routing
decisions
and due to the technology differences uh
these navigation apps for example here
the google map and apple map can
actually show different route
recommendations to their users
and this actually creates the
information he progenity experienced by
the users of different platforms and can
result in different realized um and
experience the travel time
well people will assess and compare
different apps and then this will result
in their choice of information platforms
and this leads to the equilibrium market
share of these platforms
the question we want to ask here is how
does this heterogeneous information
environment
affects the traveler's choices and the
congestion and how can we assess the
relative value of information for
different users
um so i want to convey the intuition of
this problem through a very simple
example
so we have two
routes in a network so it's a two route
parallel network
why is the highway that may or may not
have an incident when there is an
incident then the cost of the highway
will become higher but otherwise in
nominal state the highway is much
shorter than the deport
so a group of people who use information
platform knows exactly whether there is
an incident while the rest of the people
have no information of the incident
the scenario one is that this
information of incident is only shared
by
a small size of the population
what happens here is that when there is
no incident
the people who have this accurate
information will choose to take the
highway exclusively while the rest of
the people think they do not know and
because of their large sites and to
avoid congestion
some of them will take highway while the
others will take deport
however when there is actually an
incident and the informed population
knows about it they are going to switch
to exclusively take the detour
this allowed informed the population to
exclusively avoid
running into incident and they actually
experience lower cost than the other
population so in this case information
has positive value
on the other hand when information is
shared by a lot of people so the size of
the informed population is very large
the informed population can no longer
exclusively take the highway because of
its large size and the congestion
imposed by people who receive the same
information
as a result both population will split
on both routes in both states incident
or nominal and they actually experience
the same cost due to the congestion
so in this case information has zero
value what i did in this work is
basically to build a general bayesian
congestion gm framework to analyze uh
the impact of
multiple information platforms which
have heterogeneous accuracies levels of
their signals and can be potentially
correlated
um to uh to to assess how the joint
distribution of the signal as the
asymmetric information environment
on the routing behavior the selfish
rotting behavior and the congestion
so here the selfish interaction is
modeled as the bayesian wardrobe
equilibrium of this game
well we have three contributions the
first is the complete characterization
of the bayesian wardrobe equilibrium for
this general network environment and
information environment
the second is that we identify three
regimes as the changes between any
the the using population sizes of any
pair of information platforms and assess
how the relative value of information
can be positive zero or negative
so this reveals the trade-off between
the gain from having this information
versus the congestion externality
imposed by people in the same population
the third is based on the analysis of
relative value of information we analyze
when people are able to choose which
platform they want to use what will be
their choice of information and the
resulting equilibrium market share of
these platforms
well building on these results we can go
one step further to study how to design
the information environment
in order to reduce the overflow of
traffic in small residential area
and because of our analysis of the
relative value of information and choice
of information platform this allows us
to be different from the bayesian the
classical bayesian persuasion literature
in a sense that we allow the travelers
to decide if they want to receive opt-in
of receiving the signals versus opting
out
and in fact even with this flexibility
we show that the optimal information
design
can minimize the traffic overflow and
without sending the signals to all of
the people
well in a second part of multi-agent
learning i go beyond the static setting
and try to really close the loop so the
first part we studied how the
information is affecting the strategic
interaction and the outcome in the
network the system the second part i
closed the loop to study the case when
there is repeated interaction between
the platform and players in a sense that
the data that is used to estimate the
parameter is generated as the outcome of
the
of this strategic game
and this leads to the dynamic interplay
between learning of the unknown
parameter on the platform site
and learning in games with imperfect
information and there is a
repeated
repeated interplay between the two
so this leads to the non-iid data set
that is endogenously generated by the
player strategies
and i developed new tools to study this
dynamic interplay between statistical
learning and strategy learning of the
game the theoretical results we showed
includes the convergence of both the
parameter estimates and strategies
stability properties in terms of the
local and global stability as well as
under what condition this will converge
to complete learning
well the application of this theoretical
tools is to design adaptive tooling
mechanisms so this is one application
that induces socially optimal outcome in
networks with unknown latency function
and what i'm um i'm currently working on
in berkeley is to really um
extend this approach and to study the
adaptive mechanism design in dynamic
environment
well i don't have much time left so i
will just quickly mention the third part
of the work is the information
is the incentive design in networks
so recall that i mentioned the
autonomous driving can potentially
jam pack the roads
but i believe that the key here is to
design the correct incentive mechanism
to incentivize on travelers to
efficiently share the limited capacity
of the network
so i proposed a mechanic a market design
approach to incentivize this efficient
car pulling in a traffic network
the challenge here is that we need to
account for both the network topology of
this on transportation systems as well
as the integer constraints well i take
inspiration from the theory of both
combinatorial auction and the theory of
network flow problems
and developed polynomial time algorithm
for computing equilibrium of this market
mechanism
this is a brief summary i studied the
value of information and information
design in routing in general network
this is the game theoretical analysis on
the trade-off between information and
congestion
i also studied the multi-agent learning
with adaptive strategies that focuses on
bridging the interplay between
statistical learning and strategy
learning
and this leads to the learning for
totaling design
the third is the incentive design that
focuses on the computation of market
mechanism and the network and integer
constraints
so all these three aspects for uh fall
in the framework that i presented at the
beginning which is at the intercept of
game theory mechanism design and
engineering systems
thank you i can take questions
[Applause]
questions for manche
let's thank all the speakers again
so the next session will start at 11 20.